should you work with non ideal customers
this is going to be a problem that you
face in any business that you start
you're going to have the customers who
love what you do who get the value that
you provide and are willing to pay you
what you're worth and then you're going
to get other customers who like your
service like your product I willing to
pay you a certain amount but they're
never going to be ideal customers and
that's going to be most of your
customers at the start they're people
who they don't quite get it you know
they're not they're very price conscious
like if you were to increase your price
by ten percent they're gone that's not
an ideal customer for you so the
challenge for how to how to work with
ideal customers for me depends on what
stage you're at in your business ok this
question comes as a result of somebody
writing me a question this was from my
newsletter reader EO EG oma Wow hope I
pronounced that right sorry for the
pronunciation there basically she has a
dress company she designs dresses and
fabrics for people but ninety percent of
the people come into her are not ideal
customers she doesn't know what to do
the problem here is it will really
depend on what phase you're right in
your business for me what i recommend
entrepreneur's doing the first thing you
need to focus on is getting past
survival getting to the point where you
have enough money to put food on the
table and pay your bills i have a whole
set of guides that help you do that but
you have to get past survival because
it's great to have the big vision the
big idea i want that for you but if if
you run out of money you can't support
you know your mortgage payment or your
rent or pay your electricity bill you're
going to go back to get a job so step
number one is get to survival whatever
that takes how much does that mean for
you and that's not living luxuriously
its survival okay means I don't have to
get a job that's goal number one
and so that means working with less than
ideal customers and the question should
you would you rather work with less than
ideal customers or would you rather be
at a job for most people they pick
running your own business but with less
than ideal customers okay you have to
make a judgment call with each person I
remember an example when I was starting
my business I had a I was growing okay
like the for Evan Carmichael calm I was
seeing traction and I got an offer from
a big computer company I won't say the
name doesn't matter and they basically
wanted me to be a pitchman for their
company and saying we want you to go out
and say how great our company is and
tell everybody on your list and on
social media you tell everybody about
how great we are and that they need to
buy our product and they were throwing a
lot of money at me like wow this is a
lot of cash but it just it did make me
feel good you know like it was too far
it violated my belief system because I
like sharing stuff with you guys that I
use that I thought I believe in that I
think you can get value from I don't
want to say you need to go buy this
computer because it's the best computer
in the world if I'm not using it and I
don't like their product and so I had to
say no to that even though it meant
giving up a big chunk of cash and that
was that was hard but I believe that
there were better opportunities on the
horizon so there is a little bit of a
line you have to walk I would say don't
take on a customer who makes you do
something that goes against what you
believe in okay if they are making you
do something that's against your values
then they're not a good customer for you
okay that's a bad customer then you're
going to have good customers and then
you're going to have great or ideal
customers and a lot of times your
business will start with a lot of good
customers and their frustrating and they
don't get your value but what they do is
they help get you to that point of
survival and once you pass survival
you can leave them and focus on the
better clients and then you can afford
to be more selective and more picky and
hold out for the really good clients the
ideal clients and in that process you
get better at what you do right while
you're working with the good clients you
get more skilled you learn how to
deliver more value because by helping
them you are getting better yourself and
then you have more to bring to an ideal
customer to a great customer so to
summarize my advice ignore the bad
customers if they make you turn in your
stomach and you go to sleep not happy
and you're fighting your beliefs ignore
them they are not worth it for any price
keep the good customers who will get you
to your poorer survival and then start
focusing on the great ideal customers
believe for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below subscribe to the channel if if you
want to see more videos like this and
let me know you think leave a question
below ask me a question about your
business let me know you thought of this
video I'll make a video response thank
you so much and I'll see you soon